The problem with things right now, is that if one
of our nodes fails, we're left with missing data for the
file. If the node goes away for example, we've got
a 64 megabyte hole in the middle of my data.txt, and
of course similar problems with any other files that happen
to be stored on that node. To solve this problem, Hadoop
replicates each block three times, as it's stored in HDFS.
So block one doesn't just live here, it may also be
here and here. Block two is here, here and here,
and block three is here, here, and here. Hadoop just
picks three nodes at random and puts one copy of
the block on each of the three. Well actually, it's not
totally random, but that's close enough for us right now.
So now if a single node fails, it's not a problem
because we have two other copies of the block on
other nodes. And the NameNode is smart enough to see that
these blocks are now under-replicated and it will arrange
to have those block re-replicated on the cluster. So we're
back to having three copies of them. So we've taken
care of the problem, if one of our data node
fails. But there's another obvious single point of failure here.
What happens if the NameNode has a hardware problem? Might
the data be inaccessible? Or is the data in HDFS
lost forever? Or is everything fine and there's no problem?